I mean, it kind of hurts my soul a little bit, though, when you when you see the the rainbow end after like seven languages and then everything else is white because there's zero agreement on the naming of one of them is is prior adjacent transform, which we now have in C++ 23. It's called prior in Q zip with next in scholar Kotlin. I can't remember which one. And but like every language has a different name for that. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 230 recorded on April 9th, 2025.
我的意思是，当你看到彩虹在七种语言之后就结束了，剩下的全是白色，因为大家对其中一个算法的命名完全没有共识，这确实让我有点心痛。那个算法是 prior adjacent transform，我们在 C++23 中已经有了。它在 Q 中叫 prior，在 Scala 或 Kotlin 中叫 zip with next，我记不清具体是哪个了。但每种语言对它的命名都不一样。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 230 期，录制于 2025 年 4 月 9 日。
My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben we chat about a new website, Hoogl Translate. Although I probably I'm not sure also because you don't spend much time on the socials anymore or maybe this can be Part two now. We're now on episode 230. I have spun up my long-awaited Hoogl Translate website. Oh, right. In fact, maybe I'll I mean We try not to share screens here, but maybe I'll do it for a sec. And honestly, say what you will about vibe coding folks. Vibe coding is, I think the number one best thing
我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 将聊聊一个新网站：Hoogl Translate。虽然我不太确定，也许是因为你不再花太多时间在社交媒体上了，或者这可以作为第二部分。我们现在是第 230 期了。我已经启动了我期待已久的 Hoogl Translate 网站。哦，对了。事实上，也许我会……我的意思是，我们尽量不在这里共享屏幕，但也许我会演示一下。老实说，不管你怎么评价“氛围编程”（vibe coding），我认为它是这些 AI 辅助工具中最棒的一点。
about these AI assisted stuff, it is a barrier remover. You know, the reason you actually commented, I think it back on Twitter years ago, when I had, I think you commented something about like, oh, this like a graphic that I had posted is kind of like a Hoogle Translate, referencing the Haskell website. Potentially. And then I replied to that. It was so many years ago, yeah, you probably, it sounds vaguely familiar. That may have been the first time you'd heard of Ho go is that the case I don't know it had not I think I had heard of it before definitely I'd heard of it before because I had I you said who will translate and I replied I've owned the domain for like 12 days who will
它是一个障碍消除器。你知道，你几年前在 Twitter 上评论过，当时我发了一张图，你评论说这有点像 Hoogle Translate，引用了 Haskell 的网站。可能是吧。然后我回复了。那是很多年前的事了，是的，听起来有点耳熟。那可能是你第一次听说 Hoogle，是这样吗？我不知道，我之前肯定听说过，因为你说 Hoogle Translate，我回复说我已经拥有这个域名 12 天了。
translate calm okay and so like I was like floored when you had suggested I guess it's it's a pretty common like if you know of who goal this is basically that's why I called it that right it's a pretty common, like if you know of Hoogle, this is basically, that's why I called it that, right? It's a Google Translate for Hoogle. You type in one thing and you get it cross-language. And this was a site that I built in ClosureScript, like in 2023, but the reason I didn't publish it was because I already had a website spun up,
HoogleTranslate.com，好吧，所以当你建议的时候我惊呆了。我想这很常见，如果你知道 Hoogle，这基本上就是我这样命名的原因，对吧？它是 Hoogle 的 Google 翻译。你输入一个东西，就能得到跨语言的对应名称。这是我在 2023 年用 ClojureScript 构建的网站，但我没发布的原因是我已经有一个运行中的网站了，
which was my program language rankings, plrank.com. But the way that I would deploy that, I would build the ClosureScript website. It generates a main.js, and then I would always manually push that main.js, and that's what basically the website was, which is, you should be able to, with CI, recognize that there's some change, and then get like a CI to rebuild that JavaScript file and then push it for you.
那就是我的编程语言排名网站 plrank.com。但我部署它的方式是构建 ClojureScript 网站，它生成一个 main.js，然后我总是手动推送那个 main.js，这基本上就是网站的全部内容。你应该能够通过 CI 识别出变化，然后让 CI 重新构建那个 JavaScript 文件并为你推送。
I spent half a day or a day or a couple days at one point trying to figure that out, but I'm not a CI engineer and I'm also not like a front end web developer. So like I'm already out of my depths dealing with JavaScript and stuff. and stuff. And so I just gave up and I put it on my list of things to do. And I wanted to get the automatic deployment of this main.js working before I built my second ClosureScript website so that I didn't have two different, you know, bad, poorly deployed websites. It's funny when you say, and I totally echo the sentiment,
我曾花了一天或几天时间试图弄清楚这一点，但我不是 CI 工程师，也不是前端 Web 开发人员。所以我处理 JavaScript 之类的东西已经超出了我的能力范围。所以我放弃了，把它放到了待办事项列表中。我想在构建第二个 ClojureScript 网站之前让这个 main.js 的自动部署工作起来，这样我就不会有两个部署得很糟糕的网站。当你这么说时很有趣，我完全赞同这种观点，
like, you know, you're out of your depth with JavaScript. You know, my wife is a front end developer. And, you know, she thinks what I do is arcane magic and the same the other way around, right? It's like, And that's the thing is it's, it's true, like, how like how you know how you can be an expert in one thing and then you move just slightly to the right. You know, it's just a different programming language. It's just a different stack. But you don't know the idioms, you don't know the libraries to reach for. And you may know how to spell it algorithmically in your head.
你知道，你对 JavaScript 不太在行。我妻子是前端开发人员。她认为我做的事情是深奥的魔法，反之亦然，对吧？这就是事实，就像你如何能成为某一领域的专家，然后稍微向右移动一点。你知道，这只是另一种编程语言，只是不同的技术栈。但你不了解其中的惯用法，不知道该用什么库。你可能在脑海中知道如何从算法上拼写它。
But like potentially those algorithms. You need that primer to translate. You need to Google Translate. Yes, exactly. But like right potentially those algorithms you need that primer to translate you need who will translate Yes, exactly and Long story long is that I I vibe coded using Claude 3.7 got like Did like all of the plumbing of that first website got the github actions You know automatically deploying and then I did that like one day and then the next day I was like, well,
但可能那些算法，你需要那个入门指南来翻译。你需要 Hoogle Translate。是的，完全正确。长话短说，我使用 Claude 3.7 进行“氛围编程”，完成了第一个网站的所有管道工作，让 GitHub Actions 自动部署。我花了一天时间做完，第二天我就想，既然有了这个，我就可以启动 Hoogle Translate 了，尽管它已经闲置了两年。起初它只是一个极其简陋的网站，现在我有了很多设置、浅色模式等等。现在让我采访一下你关于这个网站的情况。
now that I have this, I can just go spin up who will translate, even though it's been sitting there for two years. And initially like it was just this, you know, bare-bones website. And now I've got like a bunch of settings and light mode, et cetera. Let me now interview you about this website
为了我们的听众，这是 huggletranslate.com，H-O-O-G-L-E，translate.com。Connor，它是做什么的？首页看起来非常像 Google 的首页，只有一个搜索栏和侧面的一些设置。
for our listeners. So this is huggletranslate.com, H-O-O-G-L-E, translate.com. And what does it do, Connor? So the front page here looks very much like just the sort of Google front page where you have just a search bar and a few settings off to the side.
但我们应该输入点什么。我们在这里输入什么？我会先说，我收到了很多评论，因为我发布了一个关于它的 YouTube 视频，说这是一个糟糕的名字，改个名字吧。然后有几个人说，你意识到已经有一个叫 Hoogle 的工具了吗？我说，是的，这就是我借用名字的地方。确实有一个现有的网站。如果你在 Google 上搜索 Haskell Hoogle，它就会出现。Hoogle 是一个类型签名，也就是函数声明搜索引擎。你输入函数的类型签名，它会返回所有匹配该类型签名的 Haskell 库函数。所以这是寻找你不知道名字的函数的好方法。
But we're expected to type something in. What do we type in here? And I'll start off by, I've got a lot of comments because I released a YouTube video on this saying it's a terrible name, change the name. And then a couple of people being like, you realize there's already a tool out there called Hoogle. And I'm like, yes, that's where I borrowed the name from. There is an existing website. If you Google Haskell, Hoogle, it'll come up. And Hoogle is is a type signature, aka function declaration search engine. You type in the type signature of a function and it will return you all of the functions across Haskell libraries that match that type signature. So it's a great way for finding a function that you don't know the name of.
例如，我曾经试着寻找 Python 的 in 函数。你想检查一个元素是否存在于元素列表中。在 Python 中这叫 in，在许多函数中叫 contains。事实上，如果我现在在这里输入，我会得到 Python 的 in。如果我点击 in，它在 Haskell 中叫 elem，对吧？它的一个版本叫 elem。现在你得到了一份跨语言的算法名称列表，它们共享相同的语义。所以幕后有几种不同的搜索方法。
For instance, I did it one time when trying to find the Python in function. You're trying to check is there an element that exists in a list of elements. That's called in in Python, it's called contains in many functions. In fact, if I now type in here, I'll get the Python in. And if I click on the in, it's called LM in Haskell, right? One version of it is called LM. And now you get a list across languages of the different names for algorithms that share the semantics. So behind the scenes there's a couple different searching methods.
当你只输入算法名称时，这叫“按名称搜索”。但当你点击特定语言的实现时，它会切换到“按算法 ID 搜索”，这基本上是一个映射到特定算法语义的 ID。所以有时跨语言的算法名称相同，但语义不同。一个很好的例子是 partition。所以 partition，当你输入它时，有，我不知道，15 种语言，有四种不同的颜色。这些颜色在“按算法 ID”或“按语义搜索”中意味着 partition 在不同语言中有四种不同的实现。有时它是
When you just type in an algorithm name that's called the by name search. But then when you click on a specific languages implementation that switches to a by algo ID which is basically an ID that maps to a specific semantics of an algorithm. So sometimes there's algorithms across languages that share the same name, but have different semantics. A great example of that is partition. So partition, when you type it in, has, I don't know what this 15 languages, and there's four different colors. And the colors in this by algo ID or like by semantic search means that partition across languages has four different implementations. Some of the times it's the
C++ 的 partition，你基本上得到一个一元谓词，把通过它的放在前面，没通过的放在后面。另外两种共享相同颜色的语言是 D 和 CUDA，这很合理，因为 CUDA 基本上就是 C++ 版本的并行版。其他所有基本上都是不同的实现。所以我认为 Haskell 及其相关语言的 partition，我的意思是，我实际上必须去查文档，但你可以看到当我点击 Haskell 的 partition 时，我得到了 Elixir 的 partition、copy 和 split。
C++ partition where you are basically given a unary predicate and you're putting the ones that pass it at the front and the ones that fail it at the end and the two other languages that share the same color are D and then CUDA, which makes sense because CUDA is just basically a parallel version of the C++1. And everything else is basically different implementation. So I think partition for Haskell and friends, I mean, I actually have to go to the docs, but you can see that when I click on partition for Haskell, I now get partition copy and split with an elixir.
我的猜测是你在这里写入两个独立的序列。所以你返回一个包含两个序列的元组。是的，完全正确。而不是原地修改。目前我做得有点随意。我将添加一个叫“签名搜索”的功能，这和 Hoogle 完全一样，你输入签名。目前最糟糕的情况是
And my guess is that you're writing to two separate sequences here. So you're returning a tuple of two sequences. Yes, exactly. Instead of like mutating in place. And right now I play a little bit fast and loose. I'm going to be adding something called signature search, which is the exact same as who go where you type in the signature. And like the worst offender right now
如果我输入 fold，然后点击其中一个，我会得到所有的 reduces、folds、inserts、aggregates。其中一些的语义不同，最好的查看方式是比较类型签名。很多情况下，带初始值和不带初始值的函数是有区别的。
is if I type in fold and then click on one of these, I get all the reduces, folds, inserts, aggregates. And the semantics of some of these are different and the best way to see that is if you compare the type signatures. A lot of these, there's a difference between one that takes an initial value and one that doesn't take an initial value.
通常你会看到 Kotlin 同时出现在 reduce 和 fold 中。Rust 也是一样。许多语言都是这样。区别在于它是否接受初始值。这将会被拆分。目前有一个开放的问题，说是“内置签名搜索”，然后在做这件事时，更清楚地说明我所说的“相同语义”是什么意思。我一直做得有点随意，因为从技术上讲，C++ 中的 partition copy 并不返回元组列表，对吧？它写入两个不同的序列，而且总会有……
And that's typically like you'll see Kotlin shows up both for reduce and fold. Rust is the same thing. Many languages are like this. And the difference is whether it takes an initial value or not. This is going to get split. And there's currently an issue open to say, you know, build in signature search and then while you do that, be more clear about what do I mean by, you know, same semantics. I've been playing a little bit fast and loose because technically the partition copy in C++, it doesn't return a tuple of lists, right? It writes the two different sequences and there's always gonna be...
事实上，它是唯一执行此操作的标准算法，确实如此。还有一些其他很酷的事情，比如如果你点击一种语言，它会给你所有的算法。如果我们去 C++，这里有很多语言，正如我们所预料的那样，有不同的范式，我们有 C 风格，
It is the only standard algorithm that does that in fact it is indeed yeah, and There's some other cool things that like if you this was added after the fact someone requested it if you click on a language It'll give you all the Algorithm so if we go to C++ which there are a lot of languages represented here Many as as we might expect, of different paradigms, you know, we've got the C style,
算法家族，我们可以说，C#、C、C++、Go、Python、Rust，我们有数组语言，APL，我们有 Excel，甚至在底部还有 Excel，是的，我们还有函数式语言。里面有一种语言我不知道怎么发音，我不认识，是 Crescent。是的，我想我会把它改成 Moon。你可以看到这些字符有一半无法识别。这是
the Algo family, we might say, C sharp, C, C plus plus, go, Python, Rust, we've got the array languages, APL, we were, we've got Excel at languages APL we were We've got Excel at the bottom Excel even yeah, and we've got functional languages. There was one language. I didn't know how to pronounce in there I didn't recognize it's the Crescent Yeah, this is I think I'm gonna I'm gonna change this to moon You can see that half of these characters aren't recognized. This was a
直播流的观众之一，我想是他们个人的语言。我猜这是一种数组语言。我不确定它是否是数组语言。它是一种符号字形语言，它确实有很多相同的原语转置，所以如果它是数组语言我不会感到惊讶。但这个网站的特点是，整个网站基本上运行在一个只是表格的 Markdown 文件上。然后再次感谢 Claude 3.7，我基本上建立了一个 CI 管道，每当 Markdown 文件被更改时，它就会触发一个 GitHub Action，运行一个 Python 脚本，解析 Markdown 文件，然后生成一个 ClojureScript 字典。这就是运行网站的基础。
Watcher of one of the live streams. I think their personal language. This is an array language I take it. It's a I'm not sure if it's an array language. It is a symbolic glyph language that it does have a lot of the same primitives transposed so I wouldn't be surprised if it's an array language but okay the thing about this site is is this whole site operates basically on a markdown file that is just a table. And then thanks to Claude 3.7 again, I basically built up a CI pipeline that whenever the markdown file gets changed, it kicks off a GitHub action that runs a Python script, parses the markdown file, and then generates a Clojure script dictionary. And that's what basically runs the site.
所以任何想这样做的人基本上都可以去提交一个 PR，添加任何语言或任何缺失的算法。即使是现在，如果你想添加第三方库，比如从技术上讲 range V3 在这里，但默认是隐藏的。而且在数组语言中，很多时候它们没有显式的字形，因为它是两个或三个的组合。所以你可以点击“显示表达式”，对于某些数组语言，它会向你展示，比如 any 只是所有数组语言中的 and reduction。目前我们实际上还没有添加这些，但在未来你会看到类似的东西。我添加的最酷的事情之一，因为其中一个动机是，它是一个寻找算法的有用工具。
So anyone that wants to can basically just go and open a PR and add any language or any missing algorithm. And even it's it's now that if you want to add like third party like technically range V3 is here but that's hidden by default. And then also in array languages a lot of the times they don't have explicit glyphs because it's just a combination of two or three to get that. So you can click show expressions and for certain array languages it'll show you that you know like any is just an and reduction in all the array languages. Currently right now we don't actually have those added but in the future you'll see stuff like that. And one of the coolest things that I've added because one of the like the motivation for this is one it's a useful tool for finding algorithms
你知道 Hoogle 非常有用，Hoogle Translate 也超级有用。我收到了一堆评论说，我在 Python 中工作，我知道这个东西应该存在，但不知道去 itertools 里查，这是一个库扩展。但另一个动机是，我喜欢在演讲中放入这些图表，特别是在非 C++ 会议上，当谈到 Python 时，我会说，我知道这在 C++ 中是这样，但它也叫……如果我能展示这个东西，但手动创建这些很痛苦。去处理这个需要 30 分钟。
You know who goes very useful a who will translate is is also super useful I've gotten a bunch of comments saying like I was working in Python and I I knew this thing should exist But didn't know to check in more inner tools, which is like a inner tool library extension But the other motivation is I I love putting these graphics Especially if I'm at a non C++ conference, in talks where I'm talking about Python and I'll say, I know this as this in C++, but it's also known, if I can just show this thing, but manually creating these is a pain. It takes 30 minutes to go and handle this.
所以现在它上线了，人们可以提交 PR，但我还想能够在一个漂亮的表格中展示多种语言之间的差异。所以这些天我最喜欢的是，如果你输入一种语言的名字，然后你可以输入一堆，你知道，多个这样的。所以 swap 是 C 组合子，在 Haskell 中被称为 flip，我想这里也应该有。但如果你继续输入，它会建立起来。哦，一个多列表格，在每一列显示一个算法。
So now that it's online, people can submit PRs, but I've also wanted to be able to show the differences across multiple languages in like a nice table. And so my favorite one these days is if you type the name of a language, and then you can type a bunch of, you know, multiple of these. So swap is the the C combinator known as flipping Haskell, which I guess has should be here as well. But then if you continue to type, it'll build up. Oh, a multi-column table showing each algorithm in a different column.
完全正确，并添加了一个小悲伤的表情。当该语言中缺少算法时显示悲伤表情。有时这只是因为还没添加，但具体到我们正在看的内容，我们正在看与 BQN 的 swap over 匹配的组合子，之前，我可以添加 after，然后它仍然……我想我们还没解释过，我实际上
Exactly, and adds a little sad face. Sad face for when the algorithm's missing in that language. Sometimes this is just because it hasn't been added, but specifically for what we're looking at, we're looking at the combinators in that match to BQN's swap over before, I can I can add after and then it's still and I guess we haven't explained this is that I have I don't actually
没有给这个算法命名，它基本上是在 Clojure 中创建一个频率映射。它实际上是一个叫 frequencies 的算法，相当于 counter 数据结构。事实上，如果我们复制并粘贴这个，输入 frequencies，你会看到有两种语言有叫 frequencies 的函数，Racket 和 Clojure。当我们点击这个时，这是直方图。完全正确。这是在创建一个直方图。是的。在 Python 中，惯用的做法实际上不是使用算法，而是使用 collections 中一个叫 counter 的容器，这就是为什么旁边有一个小星号，因为再一次，它做得有点随意，
have a name for the algorithm it's it's kind of basically it creates a frequency map enclosure it's actually an algorithm called frequencies where it's the equivalent of the counter data structure in fact if we copy and paste this and we type in frequencies, you'll see that there's two languages that have a function called frequencies, racket and closure. And when we click on this, this is this is histogram. Exactly. This is creating a histogram. Yeah. And in Python, the idiomatic way to do this is actually not to use an algorithm. It's to use a container from collections called counter, which is why there's a little asterisk beside this because once again, yeah, it's it's it's playing a little fast and loose,
但它使用 frequencies 来基本找出最常见的。然后我从 Excel 2003 中偷来了颜色，它有最好的调色板之一，伙计们。然后它将紫色描述为最常见的名称。然后我想蓝色是下一个最常见的，它沿着彩虹排列。所以通过这个你可以看到，over，也就是 psi 组合子，在这些数组语言中命名最一致。但其中一些，每种语言都选择了
but it uses frequencies to basically figure out what's the most common. And then I've stolen the colors from Excel 2003, which has got one of the best color palettes out there, folks. And then it describes purple to the most common name. And then I guess blue is the next most common and it goes down the rainbow and so across this you can see that you know over aka the psi combinator is the most consistently named across these array languages but then some of them like every single language chooses a
不同的名字，有些实际上没有字形。所以你可以对任何东西这样做。你可以去 C++，any，all。从技术上讲，应该是 any_of 和 all_of。但这表明，绝大多数情况下，最常见的名字是 any 和 all。如果你真的用它来为演示文稿制作图表，我已经
different name for it and some of them don't actually have the glyphs and so you can do this for anything. You can go C++, any, all. And then technically, it should be any of and all of. But then this shows that by a landslide, the most common names for this are any and all. And if you're actually using this to build up graphics for a presentation, I've
添加了功能，你可以按住 Ctrl 并点击任何行。所以如果你不想要 C#、Elm、Julia、Common Lisp 等等，去掉那些你不想放进图表的。你可以构建你想要的图表。总之，还有很多东西我会随着时间推移添加，但这是一个很棒的工具。现在我要问你的显而易见的问题是，让你输入 but last。哦，是的，这就是我们来这里的原因。所以我不认为它会在这里，但当我读硕士时，我做了很多 Smalltalk 工作，我知道 Smalltalk，特别是 Pharo 实现，确实有相当于 but last 的东西。所以我猜 init 会是那个……所以它甚至不在 Haskell 的这里，but last 也不会显示出来，但我会在
added the feature that you can control and click on any row. So if you don't want, you know, C sharp, Elm, Julia, common list, whatever, get rid of once you don't want to put in your graphic. You can build the graphic that you want. So anyways, it's, there's still lots of stuff that I'll be adding over time, but it's a it's a neat tool. Now the obvious thing for me to ask is for you to type in but last. tool. Now the obvious thing for me to ask is for you to type in but last. Oh yes that's why we came here. So I don't think it'll be here but when I was doing my masters I was doing a lot of small talk work and I know that small talk the ferro implementation specifically does have the equivalent of but last and so I guess init would be the one that so and it's not even in here from Haskell and but last won't show up either but I shall after
事后去获取这些。如果我们去 Pharo Smalltalk but last 算法，搜索 Pharo 很难，实际上我不知道为什么我们要这样做，让我们去 ChatGPT。你好，好朋友。我甚至不知道，我陷入了 Google 的陷阱，如果我没在这个播客上，我永远不会那样做。你刚才想说什么来着？嗯，我想说我们想要正确的答案。所以如果 ChatGPT 能给我们正确的答案。
the fact go and get these and if we go to ferro small tap talk but last algorithm it's very hard to search fair and actually I don't why are we doing this let's go to chat GBT. Hello, good friend. I don't even know, I got into the trap of Googling when I would never do that if I wasn't on this podcast. You were about to say something though. Well, I was gonna say we want the right answer. So if chat GPT will give us the right answer.
哦，这就是重点，如果你给它很多上下文，如果你说，我知道在 Pharo Smalltalk 中有一个算法与 Haskell 的 init 相同，它是 Common Lisp 吗？是的。Common Lisp 叫它 but last。你知道名字吗？它处理这种事情非常精准。All but last。
Oh, that's the thing is if you give it a lot of context, if you say, I know in Pharaoh small talk there is an algorithm identical to Haskell's a knit and is it common Lisp? Yeah. Common Lisp calls it but last. Do you know the name? It nails stuff like this and nails stuff like this. All but last.
All but last 在 sequenceable collection 上实现。好的。他们甚至给了我们一个小片段，使用 hash paren 表示列表。所以，是的，我应该添加这个。你可以注意到，在 Hoogle Translate 上，Pharo，我这里只有四个来自 Pharo Smalltalk 的算法，那是因为这里存在的大部分或一半东西是我两三年前感兴趣时需要的，我想大约是 300 个，但我想从一周或一周半前开始，它翻倍到了大约 600 个
All but last implemented on sequenceable collection. OK. And they even give us a little snippet using the hash paren for a list. And so, yes, I should add this. And you can note that, you know, on the Hoogl Translate, the ferro, there's only four algorithms from ferro small talk that I have here and that's because the stuff that mostly or half the stuff that exists in here was what I needed when I was interested in looking into something like two or two and a half years ago and I think that was like roughly 300 but we've I think since a week or week and a half ago it's doubled to like 600
跨语言的算法，因为人们一直在提交 PR。所以我设想在某个时候它会达到一千或两千，但是的，init，butlast，all but last。那么正确的名字是什么？嗯，在 Common Lisp 中，but last 可以接受一个可选的整数参数，所以你可以做 but last n，对吧？but last 就是 but last 1。但如果你给它一个整数，你实际上可以切掉最后 n 个。对。这是也将被内置的东西，因为现在大部分情况下，东西只映射到一个算法 ID。但随着时间的推移，带有可选参数或默认参数的东西，比如 Clojure，很多时候它们的 partition 算法，我想从技术上讲映射到几个不同的算法，通过类型签名
algorithms across languages because people have been open in pr's and so I imagine at some point it'll it'll get to like a thousand or two thousand but yes init butlast all but last so what is the correct name for well in common list but last can take an optional integral parameter so you can do but last n right but last is is but last one. But if you give it an integer you can actually chop off the last end. Right. And this is this is something that will also be built in because right now for the most part things just map to one algorithm ID. But over time things with optional parameters or default parameters like closure a lot of the times their partition algorithm I think technically maps to a couple different algorithms and with the type signature
工作，你将能够基本上将单个算法映射到多个语义，所以它会出现在每个地方。Common Lisp 也让人有些困惑。嗯，它有 n but last，因为它在算法名称中使用 n 来表示破坏性算法。N reduce 是另一个。我想 n reduce 或 n，我不记得了，但 n append，我想，n concat。这些是原地更改数据结构而不是返回新结构的算法。所以 but last 返回一个包含除最后一个元素之外的所有内容的新列表，而 but last 并不像你想象的那样与选择 n 个元素有关，但它更改了
work you'll be able to basically map a single algorithm to multiple semantics so it'll show up in every place. Common Lisp also somewhat confuses you confusingly. Well, it has n but last because it uses n in the name of an algorithm to mean a destructive algorithm. N reduce is another one. I think n reduce or n, I can't remember, but n append, I think, n concat. These are algorithms that change their data structures in place rather than returning a new one so but last return to a new list with everything but the last element and but last does not as you might think have anything to do with selecting n elements but it changes the
列表以切掉最后一个元素。有趣，这就是前缀 n 在 Common Lisp 中的含义。那是惯例，那是惯例，是的。我想 n-concat 是另一个例子。所以你给它两个列表。Concat 只是连接列表，返回连接结果。n-concat 将第一个列表的尾部设置为第二个列表。所以它有效地销毁了第一个列表或原地更改了它。你知道为什么选择前缀 N 的历史吗？
list to chop off the last element interesting that's what the prefix n stands for in common list that is, that is the conventional, that is the convention, yes. And I think n-concat is another example. So you give it two lists. Concat just concatenates the list, returns the concatenation. n-concat sets the tail of the first list to be the second list. So it effectively destroys the first list or changes it in place. Do you know why what the history but behind choosing prefix N?
我不知道为什么 N 以这种方式使用。当然，这些变体是为了效率而存在的。对。对。是的，这完全说得通。这就是这类网站的问题所在，你希望有一个清晰的，几乎严格的语义分组，将算法按语义分组。
I don't know why N is used in that way. Certainly those variations exist for efficiency. Right. Right. Yeah, that totally makes sense. And that is, I mean, that is the part of the issue of a site like this is that you want there to be like a clear, you know, almost strict how semantic, how you group algorithms by semantics.
但当你遇到像 C++ 这样的语言时，我们有一堆原地与非原地算法，它们与 underscore copy 后缀的命名不一致。在某种程度上，它们在语义上是相同的。但是，我也一直在想，我还没添加，我想有人前几天添加了 Python 的 reverse 和 reversed 作为 reverse 算法。但一个是原地，一个是
But when you get to a language like C++ where we have a smattering of in-place versus non-in-place algorithms that are inconsistently named with the underscore copy suffix is at a certain level, semantically they are the same. But, and it's also like, I've been thinking, I haven't added, I think someone actually the other day added reverse and reversed from Python for the reverse algorithm. But those are an in place versus one
返回一个副本。你知道，你如何处理这个问题？你拆分它吗，因为类型签名不同，对吧？一个返回 void，一个返回新的副本列表，新的集合。是的。或者你想出某种方式，我输入 sort，它向你展示两列，比如原地或非原地。我还没真正弄清楚。但我的意思是，这是我的……我的意思是，我过去也抱怨过这一点，sort 是原地的，transform 是非原地的。但为什么我们没有一致的命名约定，比如任何东西都加 underscore copy？所以它真的应该是 transform copy。
that's returning a copy. And you know, how do you how do you deal with that? Do you split that because the type signature is different, right? One returns void and one returns a new copy list, the new collection. Yeah. And or do you come up with some way of I type sort and it shows you two different columns of like in place or out of place. I haven't really figured that out yet. But I mean, that's one of my, I mean, I've complained about that in the past too, is that, you know, sort is in place and transform is out of place. But like, why did we not consistently like have a naming convention where it was either underscore copy for anything. So it should really be transform copy.
我们对此有点不一致，因为你可能会认为，哦，对了，这个没有 copy。因此，它一定是原地的。情况并非总是如此，对吧？是的，很有趣。Common Lisp 叫它 n。而数组语言不在乎。
And we're kind of just inconsistent with that, because you might think that like, oh, right, this one doesn't have a copy. Therefore, it must be in place. And that's not always the case, right? Yeah, interesting, though. Commonless calls it n. And array languages don't care.
我的意思是，我认为有时会有一些基于它们可以推断出只有一件事在发生的内部优化。所以它们显示所有东西都是原地的，但这并不是用户必然意识到的。是的，concat 是一个有趣的例子，或者在 Common Lisp 中是一个有趣的例子，因为常规 concat。所以 n concat 和 concat 都不必更改第二个参数，对吧？
I mean, I think sometimes there's some internal optimizations based on they can reason that there's only one thing happening. So they show everything in place, but that's not something the user necessarily necessarily is aware of. Yeah, and concat is the interesting case, or an interesting case in common list, because so regular concat. So both and concat and concat don't have to change the second argument, right?
但在 concat 的情况下，你需要创建和第一个列表中一样多的 cons 单元。你基本上创建了一个新的第一个列表，以第二个列表作为其尾部。第二个列表可以是某个东西的尾部而不知道它。所以第二个列表，因为列表实际上只是指向一个 cons 单元的指针，该单元被指定为列表的头部，对吧？其余的只是在它之后流动。所以非破坏性版本的 concat 为第一个列表分配 N 个新的 cons 单元，然后通过将其发送到尾部，仅用一个操作就附加了第二个列表。但 n concat 不需要分配。
But in the case of concat, you need to create as many cons cells as are in the first list. You basically create a new first list with the second list as its tail. The second list can be the tail of something and not know about it. So the second list, because a list is really just a pointer to a con cell, which is designated ahead of a list, right? And the rest just flow after it. So the non-destructive version of concat allocates N new concels for the first list and then appends the second list just with a single operation by sending it to the tail. But the n concat doesn't need to allocate.
它向下遍历第一个列表，当它到达末尾时，它只是将尾部设置为第二个列表。所以它将第一个列表变成了更长的列表，同时让第二个列表保持原样。为了澄清，因为 concat 可以意味着不同的事情。我的意思是，当然，我敢肯定如果我在这里输入 concat，你可以看到有多种颜色。听起来 concat 只是针对两个不同的列表？它是附加两个列表。
It steps down the first list and when it hits the end it just sets the tail to the second list. So it turns the first list into the longer list while still leaving the second list alone. And just to clarify, because concat can mean different things. I mean, sure enough, I'm sure if I type concat here, you can see there's multiple colors. It sounded like concat is just for two different lists? It's appending two lists.
明白了。好的。并返回第三个列表。是的。而我的猜测是，在这些语言中，其中一个是像 flatten，它可以接受任何列表的列表并将它们全部展平。有趣。是的。所以这完全说得通。是的。Concat 在某些 Lisp 中可能能够接受可变参数。好吧，你知道，为了简单起见，我们只考虑两个参数的版本。是的，有趣。我在想，在 C++ 中基本上……嗯，没有真正等价的。我的意思是，在 ranges 领域，他们现在有 join，但如果你在 ranges 之前
Gotcha. Okay. And returning a third list. Yeah. Whereas my guess is across these languages, one of them is like a flatten where it can take any list of lists and flatten them all. Interesting. Yeah. So that makes complete sense. Yeah. Can cat might be able to take variadic arguments in some lists. Well, you know, for know for simplicity sake let's just consider the two argument version. Yeah Interesting and I'm trying to think like in C++ basically Well, there is no really equivalent. I mean in ranges land they do have join now, but if you're pre ranges
可能是那样，对吧？如果你有 vector of vector，那些东西是静态类型的，对吧？所以你不能把它变成一维向量。所以你总是会做某种复制，非原地的复制。嗯，就像 splice。Splice 在 unordered map 或 map 中。我要说其中之一。有一个操作，还是叫 merge？我听说过 merge。我绝对没听说过 splice。哦，splice 是 std list 上的一个操作。
It might be that right Like if you have like a vector effect, like that stuff is statically typed, right? So you can't turn that into like a one dimensional vector. So you're always going to be doing some kind of copy, out of place copy. Well, it's like a splice. Splice is in unordered map or map. I'm going to say one of those. There's an operation or is it called merge? I've heard of merge. I definitely haven't heard of splice. Oh, splice is an operation on std list.
是的。好的。所以 splice 是列表版本。将元素从一个列表转移到另一个列表。没有元素被复制或移动。只有列表节点的内部指针。将元素从一个列表转移到另一个列表。没有元素被复制或移动。只有列表节点的内部指针被重新指向。是的，是一样的。好的。这说得通，对吧？因为那是 Common Lisp 的。
Yeah. Okay. So splice is the list version. Transfer elements from one list to another. No elements are copied or moved. Only the internal pointers of the list nodes. Transfer elements from one list to another. No elements are copied or moved. Only the internal pointers of the list nodes are repointed. Yeah, that's the same. OK. Which makes sense, right? Because that's common LISPs.
我假设实现是某种指针追踪的东西。有趣。好的。而且 merge 实际上也存在。我想 merge 存在于 list 上，也存在于 unordered set、unordered map、forward list 上。所以这是一个非常相似的想法。而且我认为还有一个独立的 merge 算法，我想。
I assume implementation is some kind of pointer-chasing thing. Interesting. All right. And merge actually also exists. And I think merge exists on the list and also on unordered set, unordered map, forward list. So it's a very similar sort of idea. And there's a freestanding, I think, merge algorithm as well, I think.
嗯，是的，但那是另一回事。对，merge 算法是获取两个排序序列并输出它们，并将它们压缩在一起成为第三个。同样，zip 是一个重载术语。但是的。对。总之，所以是的，我想这源于该叫 for each but last 什么名字，然后这让我想起，哦，我有一个工具可以做这个。
Well, yeah, but that's something different. Right, the merge algorithm is taking two sorted sequences and outputting them and zipping them together into a third. Again, zip is an overloaded term. But yeah. Right. Anyway, so yeah, this I guess this spun out of what to call the for each but last and then that made me think, oh, I have a tool for this.
还没完全构建好，因为它没有任何名字。你有一个还不太了解这个的工具，但它会了解的。是的，是的，随着时间的推移。这就是重点，我希望随着时间的推移，我零熟悉的语言，可能拥有扩展库的语言，比如 D 就是其中一种有很多有趣名字的语言。而 Swift，实际上，前几天，我想我知道这个
Not fully not fully built out because it doesn't have any of the names. You have a tool that doesn't quite know this yet, but they will. Yeah, yeah, over time. And that's the thing is that my hope over time is that languages that I have zero familiarity with that potentially have extents of libraries, like D is one of those languages that has a lot of interesting names. And Swift, actually, the other day, I think I knew this
但我忘了，Clojure 称他们的 scan 为 reduce，这绝大多数是为增量 fold 选择的名字，它正在打开所有运行结果，Kotlin 称之为 running reduce 和 running fold。Clojure 称 reduction 为 reduce，称 scan 为 reductions。哦，好的。好的。这很好。它是少数几个显示出
and I had forgotten it, that Clojure calls their scan, which is overwhelmingly the name chosen for the incremental fold that's opening all the running results, Cotton calls it running reduce and running fold. Clojure calls it reduce for the reduction and reductions for the scan. Oh, okay. Okay. Which is kind of nice. It's one of the few algorithms or few languages that shows that
它们在命名上相关的算法或语言之一。而且 Swift，我不知道他们是否从 Clojure 那里借用的，但 Swift 在他们的算法库中，这是标准库提供的扩展，他们也称之为 reductions，我以为 Clojure 是唯一一个。但是的，当你偶然发现不同的名字但可以说是更好的名字时，这很整洁。我的意思是，对，对。
they're related in the naming of it. And Swift also, I don't know if they borrowed it from Closure, but Swift in their algorithm library, which is an extension of what's provided in the standard library, they call it reductions as well, which I thought closure was the only one. But yeah, it's neat when you stumble on different names but that are arguably better names. I mean, it's- Right, right.
我想起了 Tails。我想在 Haskell 中它叫 Tails。它在 Lisp 中也可能叫 tails，虽然也许不是。因为那就像……这就像 prefixes。是的，他们有 init 和 init，以及 tail 和 tails。
I'm reminded of Tails. I think in Haskell it's called Tails. It might also be called tails in Lisp, although maybe not. Cause that's like- Which is like prefixes. Yeah, they have a knit and a knit, and tail and tails.
是的。那就像……是的。我忘了具体是什么了，但它类似于所有的，所以 tail 是减去头部的 Lisp，或者 Lisp 中的 cuder 和 cdr。
Yeah. That's like- Yeah. I forget exactly what it is, but it's something like all of the, so the tail is the Lisp minus the head, and the, or the cuder in lisp and the cdr and the cdr.
是的。Lisp 的人们明白你刚才说了什么。或者任何读过 SICP 的人可能也明白了。是的，我想实际上 BQN，你知道，我今天最喜欢的语言，他们有两个版本。我相信它们叫 prefixes 和 suffixes。是的，prefixes 和 suffixes，这在我脑海中可以说是一个更好的名字
Yeah. The lisp folks understand what you just said. Or anybody that's read SICP probably understood as well. Yeah, I think actually BQN, you know, my favorite language of the day, they have two versions of that. And I believe they're called prefixes and suffixes. Yeah, prefixes and suffixes, which arguably is a kind of nicer name in my head
因为 scan，很多时候，它们被称为前缀扫描，或者它们包含单词 prefix，因为它是，你正在计算 reduction 的不同前缀，是的，是的。我的意思是它非常酷，我喜欢人们向网站添加东西，因为这样它表明，你知道，有时像 filter，甚至可以说 filter，你知道，关于你是过滤进来还是过滤出去，那是否是最好的……但关于你是过滤进来还是过滤出去的对话？
because scan, a lot of the times, they're known as prefix scans, or they involve the word prefix because it is, different prefixes that you're computing the reductions of the prefixes yeah yeah I mean it is very cool I love when people add stuff to the site because then it shows that you know sometimes like filter and even arguably filter you know there's there's been conversations about are you filtering in are you filtering out is that the the best like but conversations about are you filtering in, are you filtering out?
那是最好的吗？但其中一些，你知道，filter，map 几乎是一致的，不幸的是 C++ 不是，但几乎是一致同意的。然后还有其他的，比如可能有三种语言，其中两种是 C++ 和 CUDA C++，这真的应该算作一种。然后每种语言对它都有不同的名字，这就是我们用来写作的词汇表。这是一个伟大的，这个网站对于命名很好，你知道，以及探索语言，通过探索语言，我们得到了什么是通用名称（如果有的话）的想法，或者什么是带有一些想法的名字，你知道，也因为事情在不同语言中有略微不同的签名，所以你可以探索算法周围的设计空间。是的，我的意思是，当你看到彩虹在七种语言之后就结束了，剩下的全是白色，因为大家对其中一个算法的命名完全没有共识，这确实让我有点心痛。其中一个是 prior adjacent transform，我们在 C++23 中已经有了。它在 Q 中叫 prior，在 Scala 或 Kotlin 中叫 zip with next，我记不清具体是哪个了。但每种语言对它的命名都不一样。对我来说，这是一个基础算法。我不知道有多少次，我想在你的演讲中，在 Ivan Kuchik 的演讲中，我会发错那个音。我已经很久没见过他了。但总之，多次演讲中，我都见过 zip-tail 技巧。
Is that the best? But some of them, you know, filter, map are almost unanimously, unfortunately not for C++, but almost unanimously are agreed upon. And then there's other ones where it's like there's maybe three languages and two of them are like C++ and CUDA C++, which really should count as one. And then every language has a different name for it, which is this is like the vocabulary that we use to write. It's a great, the site is good for naming, you know, as well as, as well as exploring languages and by exploring languages, we get the idea of what, what is the common name if there is one or what are some of the names with some of the ideas around this you know also because things school different names have slightly different signatures different languages right so you get to explore the design space around the algorithm. Yeah I mean it's kind of hurts my soul a little bit though when you when you see the.
我想我也在 Odin Holmes 的演讲中见过。这种模式是 adjacent transform。在我看来，它不像 map、filter 和 reduce 那样受欢迎，这真是一个遗憾，它应该和它们并列。总之，我们要结束了。Hoogle Translate。请务必查看播客应用或 adspthepodcast.com 上的节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
when you when you see the the rainbow end after like seven languages and then everything else is white because there's zero agreement on the naming of it. One of them is is prior adjacent transform which we now have in C++23. It's called prior in Q, zip with next in scholar or Kotlin I can't remember which one. But like every language has a different name for that. And to me, it's a fundamental algorithm. I don't know how many times, I think in your talks, in Ivan Kuchik's, I'm going to pronounce that wrong. It's been a while since I've met him. But anyways, multiple talks, I've seen the zip-tail trick.
感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是 Antiprase。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I think I've seen it in Odin Holmes, maybe a given talk as well. That's this pattern is a, you know, adjacent transform. And it's a real shame in my opinion that it's not as like popular as map and filter and reduce like it should be up there. Anyways, we'll wrap up. Who will translate? Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
我想我曾在Odin Holmes那里，或许是在某个演讲中见过它。这种模式就是所谓的邻近变换。在我看来，它没能像map、filter和reduce那样流行，实在是很可惜，它本应享有同等地位。总之，我们要结束了。谁来翻译？请务必查看您的播客应用或adspthepodcast.com上的节目说明，获取我们今天提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. I am the Antiprase. Um. Um. Um. Um. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听，希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。我是Antiprase。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。